Oh
We've all dealt with narcissism at one point or another in our lives whether from a co-worker
Family member friend or lover it's a draining experience
Leaving you emotionally fatigued and sapped of your energy
Sometimes it's easy to notice the signs and leave before getting hurt but sometimes
There is a cost to leaving that we cannot or do not want to pay this is most common with parents and job opportunities
It takes a whole lot of courage to make these different relationships work
Despite urgent feelings of needing to run so you don't get hurt
However there are steps
You can take to help you cope with the narcissists in your life and keep your relationships in as much ease as possible
Identify the type of narcissist you're dealing with
Researchers have categorized narcissists into two different categories
grandiose and vulnerable
Grandiose narcissists have incredibly high self esteem believing themselves to be superior to everyone else
They are the stereotypical narcissists that people think of when they hear the word narcissist
Vulnerable narcissists have low levels of self-esteem high levels of insecurity and tend to compensate by focusing only on themselves
This means they have self-absorption and self-centered tendencies
Once you know what kind of narcissist they are you can change your interactions with them to keep your relationships healthy?
Grandiose narcissists are wonderful helpers with your goals if you give them an important job and praise their work often
Vulnerable narcissists need constant reassuring that they're doing a good job
And you'll need to be sure not to accidentally offend them in the heat of a moment
While it can be difficult or frustrating
To think about where people are coming from or why they are the way they are it is key to helping you feel for them
There are always more events in a person's history that has affected them more than they let on
figuring out someone's backstory
And why they lash out the way they do can also help you handle their angry outbursts and regain patience and tolerance
While it is important to find out what the person is coming from it's equally as important to listen to your own feelings and thoughts
What actions and behaviors of theirs bothers triggers or hurts you what goals do you have pertaining your relationship?
And how are you willing to push your past feelings to maintain it?
after you take a look inside yourself and
Evaluate how you feel you can figure out where to draw the line and form boundaries and where to push forward and cope with your
Feelings in the end this experience will teach you a lesson about yourself and how to handle yourself in times of distress
Not like any other person narcissus require a gentle touch when communicating with them
It won't be as honest and open as with others nor will it be as straightforward
They may get defensive quickly
But this is because of insecurities sensitivities or lack of empathy they might have
Be careful not to let things backfire on you as you'll end up in a direct conflict
Which is never fun and was never your intention
Communicate as gently as possible without
Compromising your own values and recognize if and when you should gently step back or put your foot down as long as it is done
respectfully
If and when you put your foot down to draw some boundaries between you two be prepared to face the consequences
No matter, how gentle you were in laying down the law they will take it as a direct attack and treat it as such
depending on the person and situation
they may or may not end up resenting you it is important to remember in this time that this is part of the process and
You may not be being treated well enough by them
You are not someone who obeys them all the time
But it is better to recognize your own needs values and limits than to compromise them for someone else
While humor isn't called for in some situations it might just be your saving grace
Finding humor and a narcissists behavior may help you cope you can also call out their behaviors with a smile or a light joke
Remember to choose your time and carefully so as to not accidentally offend them and make the situation worse
Choose to keep humor to a minimum in moments of high stress anger or distress
however when a
Narcissist does something naturally and without thinking if you point it out in a light-hearted manner it is more likely to be well received
listened to and potentially corrected
Depending on how close you are to the narcissist you may have to decide if they need more help than you can provide in order
To maintain or regain a healthy relationship with people who are close to you your best friend lover or family member
Keeping a distance doesn't always feel like an option
Many psychotherapists are trained to help with this disorder and can help them and you remain healthy and happy
Remember that loving them sometimes is not enough and needing professional. Help is okay
Remember to see the positives this person obviously has positive qualities, or else you wouldn't be trying to maintain your relationship
Focus on the good qualities and the reasons why you want to make things work when you feel overwhelmed or stressed?
Integrate this into your plan so you can enjoy the most out of your relationship
For instance if you know a certain place or situation that may trigger them avoid them to the best of your ability
The same goes for conversation topics if you know of a subject that gets them going steer clear of them and talk about something else
Go out to places you can both. Enjoy yourselves and talk about things you both like talking about
Always remind yourself of why this person holds great value to you and that no one is just their disorder
Lastly it is most important to accept them while it may feel like you're walking on eggshells at times
It is important to remember that nothing they are doing that hurts. You is intentional
It is not that they do not want to see things from your point of view
But it is that they are unable to
you must accept that you will never have an equal relationship with this person if you choose to maintain your
relationship with them
This is all up to you as no one can tell you what to do
But you cannot expect them to change just for you and instead you must change your outlook and strategies to keep them in your life
If you choose remember that they are more than their disorder
That's all from us. That's like to go
What do you think about these coping mechanisms be sure to subscribe for more tips on living a healthy life